so some of these guys art you know the
site statistically it doesn't make sense
Danny that you're here on a meth case
and you got 15 years when you've been in
prison four times and you keep telling
everybody that you were caught with this
much meth and the people cooperated
against you you should have a life
sentence maybe 30 years mature you got
15 yeah you got a good story nobody
wants to question it because you're a
tough guy you're 6 foot tall you work
out all the time
you're covered in tats you've been a
state prison twice you've been to this
one guy no um should I say his name
anyway you leave that blank here anyway
ding dong so he [ __ ] you know he walks
around like he's a badass right and he's
a badass beat me to a [ __ ] pulp but
then then you don't have to be that bad
of a guy a bad of a badass mediatory
could know he could he's a piece of he's
been a state prison multiple times
[ __ ] you know he's like [ __ ]
probably closely he's like 510 511 I say
six foot he's probably 510 511 but works
out all the time white guy um meth a
meth dealer so and he's been to state
prison multiple times so the so what I'm
saying is he and I constantly move back
and forth bicker and fightin this and
that you know talking [ __ ] to each other
and hello in the low and so in the white
TV room you know like he wants to watch
this program he all he wants to do is
watch [ __ ] fishing and and that Gold
Rush and just all [ __ ] just horrible
programming yeah and and like state
troopers Alaska that it's like just a 5
billion
I can't watch all this [ __ ] fish and
[ __ ] you're not even a song about guns
you can't have a gun I won't have Matt
so so uh I used to watch Walking Dead
all the time right did you really the
only thing I ever watched show so bad
that show so horny so gloves I'm sure
loves that show and that's like me
saying that football stupid I don't like
football but I have to admit clearly
there's something I couldn't take the
[ __ ] show seriously it's just too
[ __ ] corning take it seriously the
[ __ ] little prick
Carl Oh Carl the [ __ ] walkers never
so it was so cheesy dude it was so
[ __ ] lame anyways well we can get
past our difference so they're you know
comes on like every three months and
then every three months every three
months so here's guy comes in and we
washed if you know three months and yeah
pretty much later we wash it again three
months later we're watching it so well
well the next time it comes on there's
something called broken skull ranch just
to unclear me on basically about the
same time and and so Walking Dead's
coming up and they're making the
schedule Walking Dead's on Sunday and
cook goes bro we ain't watching that
[ __ ] watching broken skull ranch and I
go that's what stone cold yeah yeah and
I go gold rules but I watch the [ __ ]
broken skull ranch to change it so I go
that we're not we're watching that and
he goes yeah we are good no we're not
and he goes yeah we are bro and I go no
we're not because I've been here [ __ ]
seven goddamn [ __ ] you know five
[ __ ] years and you're just got here
and we've been watching this for five
years I said we're gonna keep watching
it anyhow we'll [ __ ] see bro we'll
see on Sunday when that [ __ ] ain't on I
go okay we'll [ __ ] see I said well be
here with your [ __ ] boots on
[ __ ] cause I'll beat your ass I
said maybe you'll beat my ass maybe it
don't go your way
he's a [ __ ] you I [ __ ] you I get up and
walk out he's gonna kill me so you're
just hoping you scared him oh this goes
this goes back and forth but there's
always the fear of it doesn't matter
whether it's a fight or not we're both
going to shoe you know I'm saying right
fellows lose yeah we're both losing so
next day we have another bickering
argument next day it's more all day
sunday comes it's on Sunday night it's
all day long it's d-day I got my [ __ ]
boots on like I'm really like everybody
you ready get your ass ready [ __ ] go
I'm actually not going
not gonna go I mean like if he stood up
and I just [ __ ] store him off I'm not
gonna know that I'll play it up [ __ ]
with you so back and forth and guys are
like bro he [ __ ] around he's telling
everybody's and I'm telling all these
guys that watch Walking Dead we're all
going in there they're like so you're
telling me that all 15 of us go in there
you're gonna turn the channel you're
[ __ ] goddamn right I am they're like
goddamn [ __ ] you're serious huh bring
your [ __ ] boots bro not doing nothing
but so he comes to me one day so one day
so he went so like an hour before
walking dead we're in there watch it you
know just watch the TV said he we're
sitting there and waiting and wait he's
in there too oh we're both oh you're
both home it's an hour away though all
right I posted up all day [ __ ] talking
note nothing going back and forth then
really at that moment and he says oh by
the way and I go to get up to go get
some food to bring start bringing my
food and [ __ ] popcorn paka force so I go
to get my stuff and he gets up too and
we're both getting up and goes he said
uh oh I see you he makes it making come
I see you got your boots on him I don't
even [ __ ] worry about my boots bro
don't [ __ ] worry about my [ __ ] keep
my name out your mouth
all this stupid [ __ ] so he goes I go to
get up and he said he said oh I heard
about you getting your little your
little gang together all gonna come in
here so I'll slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of every [ __ ] that walks in
there I said yeah alright so we go to
what world so he gets up we're both
walking out and as we walk out he says
to me you think you think you're [ __ ]
geez you think I'm [ __ ] around I
listen listen I go
honestly I said you need to stop [ __ ]
worrying I understand I said stop
worrying about the TV and walking dead I
said because you know what's gonna
happen no matter what happens I'm yankin
the [ __ ] TV off the wall and we're
both going to the Shu and we're both
gonna watch it together in the [ __ ]
shoe do you understand I said that's how
[ __ ] serious I am I said you can stop
war and just stop worrying about the
[ __ ] here's what you need to worry about
cook
start worrying about where they're gonna
send you because you better hope because
they're gonna ship send them to another
prison with local in different prisons
there you better [ __ ] hope they don't
send you out west where they're asking
for paperwork that we both know you
can't provide and he goes so somebody
say somebody say something I go yeah
yeah whoo and I go you did just now he
goes and he goes I said you I said you
should have a 25 year minimum mandatory
you got less than 15 oh you see they
looked at me and he goes man you know
I'm just [ __ ] around about that [ __ ]
you can watch that [ __ ] though I mean
I'm good with you you know I'm just
playing man I'm just playing I said I
know you're playing I was playing too
man I'm so good we're good we're good
yeah we're good we're good though I go
yeah we're good he was okay he [ __ ]
goes in gets his chair brings his chair
out [ __ ] everything we go in we watch
walking bet it was I can't believe he's
[ __ ] and I'm like totally [ __ ]
bluffed his ass I mean he would've beat
me to a pulp
you